let's just bring you this which is the
latest image that we have of nazanin
zagari radcliffe a
broad smile on her face there this is
from tulip sadiq her local mp
and the tweet says it's been six long
years and i can't believe i can finally
share this photo
nazanin is now in the air flying away
from six years of hell in iran
my heart goes out to gabriela and
richard as her long journey back home to
them gets closer by the minute and the
hashtag below nazanin is free
uh dominic our diplomatic editor is here
with us um dominic do we know anything
about how she will get home direct
flight from tehran to london unlikely or
will she go to a different country first
it's likely she's going to go to a
different country on the way back
possibly oman that paid some kind of
role in these negotiations and then
she'll be flying back here this evening
we're told we're not sure where she'll
be landing which airport but it will be
late this evening and um and that's a
third country if you like she's going to
presumably get a chance to decompress a
bit um and talk to
foreign office diplomats about her
ordeal but i mean that that pitch is
amazing isn't i mean she looks she looks
incredibly well she looks very happy she
looks tired um but you know not
surprising but she you can see the
relief on her face can't you she sits
there on that plane and and she's
literally just taken off about five
minutes ago i was told that she was on
the plane but hadn't taken off and i
think the expectation from
the family and their lawyers were that
she was going to take off well
three and a half hours ago so i think
that led to enormous amount of anxiety
because they have been plagued by the
iranian authorities you have to stress
this over the years the iranians have
toyed with them
knowing that she's a high-profile name
knowing that they are trying to milk it
for publicity they've raised the
possibility of her being released both
in negotiations and in what they've been
saying publicly only to have the hopes
that those raised in her family's mind
dashed and i think you know even to the
last minutes they must have been
thinking there's a possibility this
could go wrong even though everything
was going in the right direction now
finally
she is on a plane and flying home
confirmed by her local mp and by the
foreign secretary who has played
a very strong role in this and she has
succeeded liz trust where all her
predecessors have failed and we
understand that she's pushed very hard
with this she's made it very clear to
her iranian foreign counterpart that she
wanted this sorted out and she's managed
with her diplomats to secure the release
of nazanin and anusha ashuri uh you know
although all those before have failed to
do so
and confirmed by her and also the prime
minister uh who tweeted a short time ago
i'm very pleased to confirm that the
unfair detention of nazanin zagari
radcliffe and anusha ashori in iran has
ended today
and they will now return to the uk
and
everybody has been dancing around their
words
so carefully uh in relation to this case
in relation to her detention for so long
the prime minister there though saying
calling her detention unfair
yeah the same same man boris johnson of
course back in 2017 i think it was when
he was foreign secretary uh landed her
in a lot more trouble boris johnson
telling mps that she had been in iran
training journalists where she'd only
been there on holiday
uh introducing her daughter to um her
grandparents and asean's parents and
that clip of him saying that to mps but
he just he seems not to have read his
brief he just wasn't on top of things
got it completely wrong that clip just
got played over and over again on
iranian state tv and it led to her
spending more time in jail so he can
sigh a big sigh of relief as well
because
someone who's he's you know
caused a lot of trouble to is now coming
home he can relax as well as everyone
else watching on
and she's going to be back late tonight
we think um gabriella only seven uh very
very excited according to her lawyer one
imagines she'll probably be allowed to
stay up past her bedtime tonight she's a
she's a girl that has her own mind um
she's a very
she's a very bright girl and she's um
very charming and um she either wants to
be filmed or she doesn't if she doesn't
want to be filmed then she's not going
to be filmed and richie can't do
anything about it so she knows exactly
what what she wants and she has asked
over and over again when is mummy coming
home and that's been very difficult
question for richard to answer
particularly when hopes have been raised
you know and i think towards the end of
last year there was the hope that it was
going to happen and the christmas before
that and last summer there was a clear
sign that things were going to move in a
direction to her coming home and then
they were dashed as well those hates
were dashed and gabriella at each point
i think richard has been pretty frank
with gabriella there's a possibility of
her mother coming home and has had to be
honest when it's not going to happen we
were told by the family's lawyers that
she was a very excited young girl this
morning when she was told of the
possibility again
and finally
her dreams have come true her mother is
returning
tell us a little bit about anishi ashuri
um
he is also free today he is also on that
play not quite as much uh media focus on
him but for his family an enormous
relief also yeah anisha shuri is 68 year
old retired civil engineer um he was
arrested a few years ago and charged
with spying as well um to the obvious
shock and conservation of his family uh
sherry hazardi his wife
and their children
and you know she told me that they'd
live a fairly normal existence in south
london
he was a very devoted family man he had
built at the end of their garden a
hobbit house because she loves the
hobbit she loves jr tolkien books
and it wasn't completed because he was
arrested so another completely unlikely
candidates to choose and accuse of
spying and part of what's going on here
with iranians is they're choosing people
who clearly aren't spies
but making it clear they're kind of
hostages and that they are pawns in a
game of hostage diplomacy that the
iranians very cynically play because
they want to have concessions from the
west so anusha is um someone who's
family have been extremely concerned
about he's he's been able to smuggle out
recordings
pleading for help and at times he sound
fairly robust at other times he sounded
very dejected and very down and at times
they thought that even though he's a man
of extraordinary kind of optimism
normally in positivity his wife told me
she was worried that he might try and
take his life at times during his
incarceration so she of course hugely
believed as well i think they decided
early on that they would follow foreign
office advice and and not publicize his
case and then decided that they weren't
getting anywhere they weren't getting
the answers they wanted from the foreign
office diplomats
they said to me we're kind of going
through the motions and so they started
publicizing his case as well but not as
high a profile as richard has with
nazaneen
but clearly that that strategy has
worked as well as long as well as the
hours and hours of diplomatic
negotiations the foreign office have put
into this to bring this day about
and in terms of his mental health
gabriella and sorry nazanin's also
uh has been a focus she's she had
periods of time in captivity where she
seemed to cope well and other times
where
it just really just all became too much
for her yeah absolutely i mean she um
she's a very strong woman clearly she's
gone through hopes being raised hunger
strikes
being incarcerated in very bad
conditions
um thinking that she was going to get
out and then realizing that she wasn't
and richard's described the phone calls
he's had with her trying to console her
trying to find ways of reassuring her
and sometimes you're simply being lost
for words
but she has a strength i mean they've
both been through an ordeal that i think
would lead
many people to end up broken i mean just
unable to cope but she's managed to find
the strength of character and the
resilience um as has richard to get
through this and yeah at times um he
was worried that she'd also commit
suicide and was very worried about the
hunger strikes but he always believed he
told me that this day would come he
couldn't not believe in that but he
wasn't able to think beyond a few days
at a time he's always thought i'll get
through this i'll get through the next
week and then we'll see where it goes
because if you think too far ahead
he said you can end up going mad